over the last few decades evidence has
accrued in an incontrovertible manner
that the rate of expansion is actually
increasing rather than decreasing and I
believe that's the great mystery that's
propelled scientists who posit the
existence of such phenomena as dark
energy have I got that right by adding
in matter you get anti-gravity or you
add an energy Pure Energy you get a form
of anti-gravity almost as if it's a
comic book Heroes a dream that you could
suspend gravity that you could freeze
the motion of objects that tend to want
to combine with one another so he then
had a mechanism contrived as it was to
explain why the universe appeared static
as it did in 1920 and 1919 but then as I
mentioned earlier when Hubble observed
the universe is in fact not static hair
Einstein the universe is expanding then
Einstein had the Brilliance the humility
and the confidence to say I was wrong